feel like I can sum up this review Right
Here Right Now what's the quality of
this movie it's like this I walked out
of the movie theater I saw the poster I
did a double take I was like a [__] that
makes more sense so here we
[Music]
go wish upon When You Wish
Upon what there's more wish upon what so
wish upon is I guess it's a horror movie
it's not really any one genre I was like
maybe it's a thriller no it's not really
it doesn't it's not good at anything but
horror is the closest thing it is so
horror is what it is it's a horror movie
where this girl she's not really popular
in high school she's kind of an [__]
but I'll get to that in a second but her
dad goes dumpster diving because eBay's
not going to feed itself and he finds
this weird box is like hey you like this
kind of [__] here so she's like all
right and I wish that this girl would
just rot cuz this girl is an [__] to
her in school you know she's the bully
she's the princess so sure enough the
next day this girl gets necrotizing
fascitis holy [__] it works this is why
she's an [__] though because right
then and there they're all like oh oh
she's rotting awesome who knew Karma was
a bigger [__] than her mhm I'm like
that's necrotizing f is like I had
problems in junior high and high school
there were some people who were some
dick heads to me but if I learned that
one of them got a flesh eating bacteria
that could kill you my first reaction
wouldn't be like he I'd be like are they
all right yeah they were a dick but [__]
I mean are they going to live not this
girl and that's the premise of the movie
this girl has seven wishes with this box
she starts wishing for things but with
every wish someone's going to die magic
comes with a prize Deary and at first
you kind of give her slack because the
deaths aren't so apparent that it's link
she you wouldn't know that there is a
causality but at a point she clearly
does believe in the wishes and then she
starts knowing oh God people are dying
she keeps wishing after that then yeah
she's an [__] but really the movie
was boring I was so bored man I got the
Restless Leg Syndrome I'm like come on
not just something happened because
things are happening something happened
in a well-edited manner in a cohesive
plot with characters you give a [__]
about and have that something be
interesting or at least tension filled
there just kind of things happen and the
acting well the acting's not good there
are a couple of moments where people
have to show pain because someone close
to them died and I'm like it didn't
quite stick that Landing is that the
best take you got or is it just there
like one take and we move on works for
Clint Eastwood and when the people die
it's not really like Final Destination
esque you can tell it wants to be but in
execution it's like someone was like
okay I want to make like Final
Destination with none of the budget none
of the talent and just make it one step
and they're dead final destination at
least built the tension around every
kill it was the point of every Final
Destination movie how is someone going
to bite it it's going to be really
elaborate holy [__] just like Mouse
trapped from hell at least in that you
had entertainment and that freeway scene
in the second one was [__] business
way chapon doesn't have any of the
elaborate nature of the kills that that
movie had really the binder that thing
that holds this movie together is what I
relate to most in life oh you know it
teenage girl drama who gives a [__] any
girls out there going through teenage
girl drama I know when you're in it it
matters I'm going to let you know a
secret it doesn't [__] matter when
you graduate you're going to wonder how
you ever got wrapped up in giving a [__]
about things so small in life there is
one scene that actually offers some
tension or at least mystery because
every scene where someone dies leading
up to it it's just like like oh it's
concentrating on that person things are
happening all right that person's going
to die oh look at that the person died
but in one scene it divides it it
concentrates on two people who both look
like they're going towards Peril and you
don't know which one's going to bite it
it's hands down the most interesting
part in the movie even then in the
execution I'm like ah you guys just
didn't have the budget to make that look
good did you as in the end will jaapan
was garbage it was crap it wasn't scary
it wasn't tension filled it wasn't even
interesting it's an interesting premise
but I feel like the premise would be
better suited for like an episode of The
Twilight Zone or YouTube short film or
something it just felt like I we got to
draw this out for seven
wishes any ideas I was bored and I
couldn't wait to leave the movie theater
wish aon's a crappy horror movie and
wish Aon is dog [__] there even scene
for this girl girl gets into a fight
with the manger it's like a little
scuffle cuz they're friends and she gets
pushed down the stairs but it's this
awkward
like oh like how that just looks sad all
right guys so wish upon you're not going
to see it you're not come on please
don't do that to yourselves what's your
favorite Final Destination movie that's
what I'll ask you whatever you think
whatever it is comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see
more
[Music]